speaking of which i got sent this thread
by rob henderson earlier on which is
really interesting could the matching
imbalance on tinder and other dating
apps be a factor in the rise of the
incel movement and young men reporting
low sexual activity so there's a graph
here that says the uh young men a share
of men and women between the ages of 18
and 30 reporting no sex in the past year
and that has gone up from 10 to 30
percent
for men
since
uh around about 2010
to 2020 to now right so over the last
decade the number of men reporting no
sex in the last year has tripled and the
uh line on the graph has got where
tinder's introduced and it is exactly
when
men
wear that that inflection for men
beginning to go from the 10 to the 20 to
28
women also actually um stay flat for a
little while but have increased
which is also very interesting um wealth
in tinder is not distributed equally
attractive guys have more wealth in the
tinder economy they get more likes than
unattractive guys that's the bottom 80
percent of men bottom 20 of women top 80
of women top 20 of men think which a lot
of people are familiar with um there's a
thing called a guinea coefficient or a
genie coefficient which works out how
much inefficiency there is within a
system so it's used to look at uh
economies within countries uh and the
lower that the number is the um more
uh equality there is uh within wealth
distribution so
if modern dating apps were a country it
would be one of the most unequal in the
world the tinder economy has a higher
genie coefficient
than 95.1 percent of the countries in
the world it's just below south africa
it's above venice it's disparity
yeah it's above venezuela and just below
south africa that's where it sits uh
according to open source data a man of
average attractiveness can only be
expected to be liked by slightly less
than one percent of females 0.87 on
tinder this equates to one like for
every 115 females and men in the bottom
10 percent see just one match per week
at most
ultimately most women only swipe on a
handful of men per day while men are
more freewheeling with their swipes so
yeah men females pass on 95 and like on
five and men are basically 50 50 left
and right um
it's just
so we
we had talked about tinder before
and
one thing that i think is actually
really interesting was
before tinder
there were websites like e-harmony you
remember that
um
and the way that the way that we looked
at it you know the the guys in my friend
group the people my age we looked at it
as like oh what a weird [ __ ] idea
online dating super weird you're weird
like it's it was just kind of like what
the hell and then here's tinder this fun
little swipey thing it's kind of about
hookups it's everyone
it's a meme right it's it's a it's a
it's like a meta commentary it's just
like this is hilarious
we're swiping it's hilarious we match oh
what's up like
and then almost immediately after that
online dating becomes something serious
it becomes something like well i haven't
gotten any dates let me go online there
was really there's really not much
resisting
to whether it's cool or not you can
resist whether you want to do it or
whether it's legit or not or or if the
masses are doing it but if someone says
hey i'm on hinge
or i'm on tinder they're not going to
get made fun of because it's just the
masses are doing that whereas eharmony
and match.com like if you had done that
at the time where they were very
prevalent for i think older generations
um it was definitely seen as a weird
thing that's the same as anything though
right there's adoption adoption curves
happening
it wasn't like we all jumped on eharmony
we all jumped on the hookup app
that made this
the location services was i think the
thing
you are in the same location as that
person here's a picture of them
do what you want with it
rather than this kind of weird um almost
like my spacey type of
aol vibe to it which you would get from
eharmonyandmash.com yeah maybe on the
tinder thing you get this more you get
this handheld
you know location services this app on
your device that good user experience
separates it
why do you think it would be that the
introduction of tinder
would
increase the number of men reporting no
sex you think it's just women do you
think that what this guy's implying in
the thread is because of this high
inequality that women are sort of
wistfully chasing after the eight out of
tens and above for guys and they're not
giving any attention to the dudes at the
bottom because you would have presumed
maybe if you hadn't been able to work
out what was actually going to go on
everyone's talking to everyone more that
should facilitate more casual sex for
everybody overall but what it seems has
happened is the gains have been
sort of accrued to the very few
super chads at the top and then there's
this big sexless underclass of men that
is now 30 of men reporting no sex within
the last year
yeah i mean more matches for the female
would mean
uh
you know why would you take the
male that you're less attracted to
right like why would you take the
opportunity if you know you can match
with more and more and more and more
people you're going to leave out a very
large chunk of other people where men
apparently do not have that option
so yeah i mean it's they're just chasing
after the potential match that they know
is more likely going to happen
maybe if those two people meet like
this is also another thing women are
and men are now looking at their
potential mate through the lens of looks
whereas before
you might not think someone is
attractive until there's some sort of
action that makes them attractive
whether that's someone in your class or
uh you know someone you go to the gym
with or whatever
that interaction is what makes them
attractive and
then you're looking at someone who if
you saw their tinder profile or if you
saw their hinge profile you would not
have swiped
so maybe that's occurring less
you know
potential mates like
you just had on a guest who said that
the worst quality to look for for a
long-term relationship is looks
conventional business yeah and that is
exactly what people are looking at when
they get these apps well i think that
this probably explains
a big chunk of why
relationships are now increasingly short
and this is something that people don't
necessarily see
so it's easy to say um there is now a
global sexual marketplace um anybody
with an instagram account or a tinder
account can basically be in the entire
world's
sexual marketplace right they can be
dating somebody in guatemala or bali or
germany or wherever they want
and therefore that means that people are
mate switching more easily because the
friction of doing that is
lower and because the number of
competitors for whoever your mate is is
significantly higher now and that women
will lilly pad from one guy to one guy
from one chad to one chad to the next
one
now the thing that seth stevens
davidowitz said that was really
interesting is that the algorithms can
predict what you're going to click on
unbelievably well they will be able to
predict with like insane accuracy
whether you'll swipe left or right on
someone and the algorithms can do
basically nothing to work out whether or
not you'll have long term happiness and
where the relationship will last long
term so
for the people that didn't see the
episode
um the
things that are most often used as cues
for whether or not someone will swipe
right or left are things like height
conventional attractiveness wealth level
and job right those are some of the the
most common things that are used
these have
zero
basically zero correlation with whether
or not a relationship is happy long term
those things were psychological
stability conscientiousness
um a growth mindset a bunch of other
things
none of which can be displayed on a
tinder profile i can't tell whether
you've got a growth mindset or whether
you're
somebody that's psychologically
sustainable yep precisely in fact you
might be able to try and signal
precisely that through your looks and
then have the complete opposite you can
put window dressing up as much as you
want so my point being that
what people are doing now is optimizing
for the wrong parameters people are
optimizing for things which are
completely arbitrary when it comes to
long-term relationship happiness for
girls things like height i think it's
something like
80 percent of women on hinge have their
height limit set to six foot or above
for men
that's
less than 10 i want to say less than 10
or 15 percent of men
in the united states are above six foot
and yet that and
height has zero predictive ability
when it comes to looking at long-term
relationship happiness imagine you
saying to me dude i only date girls who
are a size four and a half shoe
i'd be like
why
why i know that this has no it bearing
on whether or not you're going to be
happy in this relationship but you just
pick this arbitrary thing because it's
become captured by the culture that
girls that the size four and a half feet
do you know what i have a great i almost
have a
reasoning for that having and this is
anecdotal but i i
feel as though
girls hold more of an animus towards
these dating apps
so that they say
look if i'm gonna get on hinge i'm gonna
get the best of the best and if it
doesn't work
no problems for me i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] if i get one match if
i get 10 matches i don't care
i'm on this thing
to not get [ __ ] over but i if i'm
gonna get someone they better be tall
they better be good-looking they better
read this this and this
where
maybe it's not the the same approach for
men
right i i i can honestly say that i've
heard many many women just say like it's
almost like the dating app owes them for
being because they resent the fact that
they maybe they resent the idea that
they're there yes
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace